hey guys it is Friday again which means
I've got five of the biggest stories of
this week all ready to go for you here's
what you need to know Dead or Alive
Xtreme 3 a spinoff from the fighting
game of the same name won't be shipping
worldwide as its publishers seem to be
concerned about how its depiction of
women will go down Dead or Alive Xtreme
3 is a boy Ristic beach volleyball game
which features scantily clad female
characters who you can dress up in
various costumes it's set to arrive in
Japan on Vita and ps4 in February of
next year but there won't be a Western
release publisher koei tecmo explained
in a roughly translated facebook comment
that they spent a couple of years coming
to the final decision to not distribute
the game globally for those that have
released a beta update for fallout 4
this week which is a work in progress
for its first pass the one point two
point three three update is available
now on PC the players who've opted in to
receive beta update on Steam the pouch
introduces a number of new features
including the ability to bring up number
pad keys and rebuffing activate now
works on quick container menus the
update also includes a number of bug
fixes and stability improvements related
to certain quests but as de house dress
this update is not final in its current
state and you should backup your saves
before you opt into it
december's free playstation plus games
and the xbox games with gold have been
revealed enhancement you can pick up on
ps4 you can grab the first chapter of
the new kings quest and gauntlets layer
edition while the ps3 offerings include
far cry 3 blood dragon and SSX VD users
can grab themselves freedom wars and
rocket birds hard boiled chicken on xbox
one you can get the incredible
adventures of van Helsing for free all
month and thief from December 16 to
January 15 for the first half of
December you can get castlestorm for
free on xbox 360 while the second half
of the month will deliver sacred 3 and
operation flashpoint dragon rising
Microsoft have said that all 360 games
released through games with gold will be
backwards compatible on xbox one destiny
has a new refer-a-friend system and its
offering a bunch of exclusive rewards
the rewards include three new legendary
swords called the elemental King blades
as well as the duo dance and high five
and moats there's also a new emblem a
shader and a sweet easy 34 vector
infinite Sparrow these rewards can be
earned by referring someone to the game
having them by and play on the same
platform as you and then completing a
new quest called the hunt for loot
together Bungie have published a fairly
complex faq on their site to explain the
nitty-gritty of the system if you want
to find out more
earlier this week the frontman for
breaking benjamin destroyed a copy of
star wars battlefront and called the
game a piece of [ __ ] well it's been
peace still not all that keen on it
after posting up a picture of the broken
disk on his Instagram and raging at how
crap it was radio station 94.3 w cy y
caught up with the vocalist Benjamin
Burnley finally said a group presumably
representing EA asked him to talk
positively about the game on his social
media channels and he agreed so long as
he liked it long story short he did not
he explained it [ __ ] sucks the
gameplay sucks all online games suck in
their own kind of way because you're
relying on the internet it's just not
fun his reasons for said lack of fun
included what he described as poor spawn
placements over powered weapons a lack
of a reward system and bad hit detection
let me know down in the comments what
you cared about this week and if you're
planning on picking up any games on the
cheek from this weekend this week on
site to find out where all the awesome
black friday sales are taking place I
tell you about the best Easter eggs in
fallout 4 on the chest and Lucy talks
through how to survive a nuclear blast
on reality check that is it for me this
week have a lovely thanksgiving weekend
if you're celebrating and i will catch
you again on monday